Fujitsu is a computer brand known for their computers and tablets...
...mainly for the professional fields, medical offices, and sales force automation.
But they are a huge company in Japan involved in many things including robotics.
And what they've developed here is a concept bear...
...that is stuffed with software and a camera and sensors...
...that actually react to the way you act in the room.
The bear has a built-in webcam in its nose...
...and facial recognition software inside the bear can detect what kind of mood you're in.
If you're happy or sad or even crying.
And of course, it has sensors built in so if you tickle the bear, it actually interacts with you.
Touch the bear in a bad way and it actually scowls at you.
Now, Fujitsu is developing this bear as a companion for the elderly in Japan.
The idea is that you'll interact with the bear, and keep alert and active.
But it also proves some of the technology that Fujitsu is working on.
The camera has facial recognitions to determine what your mood is.
If you're smiling, happy, sad, drowsy.
And some of the advanced capabilities that you'll have in this bear...
...is it can detect if you've fallen and can't get up,...
...it'll alert people to what you're doing and just keep track of you.
Now, obviously this is just a concept bear and slated only for Japan...
...but we couldn't wait to see this in the United States.
After all, doesn't Teddy Ruxspin need an update?
For Consumer Reports, I'm Paul Eng.